Syst of a number of reports which we are
to listen to reports on the visions
which were made and implementing order
to support individuals and the economy
and the second part of our conference
will deal with how we are to gradually
lift the restriction in Russia I'd like
to remind you about the key packages of
measures implemented one after another
they were supplementary each other
taking the situation into consideration
we decided to take a step by step
program to hold small medium sized
companies and large companies as Wells
Monty
top priority decisions were payments the
families with children doctors health
care professionals increased benefits
for those who after March the 1st was
left unemployed 8 subsidies and
subsidized companies those who
maintained drop levels without firing
anyone wavers on the rent and tax
payments as well as some additional
measures we're taking in the result of a
number of meetings that we had to
support the critical infrastructure and
industries the automobile industry
banking oil and gas rocket and space
exploration industries among others
tomorrow we'll be discussing the
transportation today I'd like to hear
from you on how these have been
functioning about their results about
the people and the companies which have
already received that help or will
receive it in the immediate future not
some some a later date but a specific
date which we outline beforehand of
course I would like to hear about more
details on the problems that we have and
the action they should take in order to
resolve these problems including
adjusting the
another critical issue another critical
point of the agenda is the following I
instructed to come up with a number of
measures to allow for a very strands
ition out of the restriction regime by
negative faith and I worked with the
government and the federal service for
surveillance on human rights protection
and human well-being and today I'm ready
to listen to your solutions I would also
like to reach out to every governor in
the Russian Federation because you may
stand these guidelines should be work
out your own plans the time after May 12
the life is way less predictable that
any scenario scheme that is why you
should have a well calculated algorithm
for actions to be taken still the
situation with the Corbett 19 outbreak
in different regions is well different
there is no one single template on where
we have to adopt strict measures and
they should be maintained even to be
made even more rigid and sometimes they
can be eat out that can be done only in
close coordination with experts and
healthcare professionals take into
account all the risks and factors we
should not be getting ahead of ourselves
any failure in your mission can put us
back and be a throwback we may risk the
lives of our people and we will be
responsible that we are highly
responsible for any mistake that we make
let's not forget about that
unless ice over to the first point in
our agenda that is the reports of the
decisions made and plans implemented I'd
like to give the floor to the Minister
of Social Welfare
mr. Burton first of all I would like to
talk about the support for families
starting from 7th April families with
children have been receiving over 5,000
rubles for every child above three years
old overall one point over 1.7 million
children have received support many
families have already used the family
benefits they're also providing other
support and benefits to receive this
benefits
citizens on the need to send an online
form through the government website
most people use this electronic type of
applying for the benefits the whole
procedure takes less than five days I'd
like to say that we believe that over
3.2 million children will be able to
receive the benefits to the 1st of July
this year starting April we move to a
different type of procedure so the
family receives a certificate and they
can use this receipt if occur to receive
the benefit on the 1st of June a month
before than we planned
we are going to start providing monthly
payments to families with children aged
3 to 7
this will be 50% of the of the minimum
wage in the region I'd like to say that
by today we have all the required
legislation and laws and regulations to
do that
apart from that we after that platforms
to start accepting applications for
these benefits so this was all starts on
June 1st
like I said everything can be done at a
distance through our website through
State Services website those who have
know those who cannot do that you can
physically come to the State Services
Center and of course the benefits will
depend on the types of documents that
the citizens will provide they will not
take into account the salaries the
current positions of the parents if one
of the at least one of the parents is
currently unemployed according to our
estimates before the end of this year
over two million children will receive
these benefits another category of
citizens that are currently very
vulnerable to the Cova Depa demmick are
of course senior citizens since the
start of April we had a special
procedure for hospitalization for and
for for going to the hospital for people
65 years and older so all the all the
necessary data could be provided from
the employer cetera
so the the number this cyclists is over
1 million already been issued now as for
the people who are currently unemployed
out of job will increase the
unemployment benefit from eight to
twelve thousand rubles the procedure for
applying for unemployment benefits will
be easier this can be done through the
government website State Services
website also people will be able to fill
in their resume for further employment
there will be a different procedure are
the documents such as for example
documents from the previous employable
nods are required to apply all these
benefits
we are currently cooperating with the
pension fund to roll out this program
also doing everything to get as much
information as possible about our
citizens to facilitate this program so
you can apply for the unemployment
benefits through the website more and
more people are doing that we currently
have 1 million two hundred forty three
thousand people are unemployed and seven
hundred thirty five thousand people have
registered for the benefits the amount
of the benefit if the person lost his
job before the May third before March
first then the benefits amount world
depend on his on how how long he has
worked before however if the person lost
his job after March first then he will
get the highest amount of benefit with
just over twelve thousand rubles there
are special measures for support for
families where at least one parent lost
his job after March 1st this case in
April in June these people the amount of
unemployment benefits will be increased
using special calculations 30,000 people
are receiving benefits like this at this
moment we're doing thousands of children
we are assessing the the income of these
families we used to assess this but now
in this situation we are providing
benefits of regardless of the income our
agency and the pension fund are
collecting info that will be used by the
federal taxation service to make
decisions on providing employers with
payments for their employees depending
on a number of statistics based data
will be provided to the federal taxation
service and then will result in the
specific number the specific amount the
psychic report I think will get back to
you after we finish with the voice going
to now agenda now let's give other
colleagues of ours an opportunity see
deliver their reports and now let's pass
over to the Ministry of Health
good afternoon mr. Putin good afternoon
colleagues today Russian Federation has
over one eye with 60,000 to probably 19
patients Russian hospitals confirmed
cases estimate at 80,000 people 135
patients are on ventilators four of them
are children some adults are on ECMO
right now helping oxygen into their
circulation system today we have a lot
of patients about 65 years of age those
with diabetes obesity and cardiovascular
diseases we also see that man are
usually more susceptible than women we
are training the medical staff in order
to increase the quality of medical
services 1.4 million health
professionals have already been
retrained we have thousands of thousands
of doctors and nurses now working hard
to provide necessary medical help such
as doctors and nurses minor health care
staff together with ambulance drivers we
have brought you work thousands of
students that is 41,000 of them students
are working in red zone only if and when
they have given their consent if they
don't have any medical problems which
would preclude them from doing that and
certainly they have all past necessary
training before working in the red zone
we have a number of volunteers we have
over 5,000 medical professionals working
as volunteers
starting with April the first would have
started issuing bonuses for medical
professionals across Russia those who
work with public 19 patients government
has
kated t 5.7 billion rubles most of the
monies go into the regions billion for
those working in the federal
institutions and those work at the law
enforcement hospitals and Ministry of
Defense hospitals to them three billion
rubles will be allocated we have very
good the way we have stopped also the
people will be relieved from paying
taxes on this bonuses we have issued in
a three law and they also will get
additional bonuses based on the local
documentation compiled for their work
all the allegations are made on time
according to the shadows for salary
payments throughout April the medical
institutions have already received over
six billion rubles to pay one hundred
forty three thousand medical
professionals such bonuses allocated in
the amount of several billion rubles
starting from January to the teeth as a
mayor first we have given out several
billion rubles already exactly people in
aid bill rubles to thousands of doctors
across Russia a health care ministry has
issued guidelines to the regions of
Russia explaining how these bonuses
should be paid and to whom exactly as
well as we urge them to pay these
bonuses as soon as possible this data
has been sent to governor's reminding
them that all the regional bonuses
should be also capped in place there was
another question as to what legislation
was put in place to ease the strain on
the medical workers
because there are certain qualification
categories of doctors we started to
extend the expiration dates on the
confirmation of those categories for one
year will be viable all the way through
2021 good into your instruction to
ensure that the medical workers and
professionals have their insurance in
place we have maybe the decision to
offer additional issuance guarantees to
certain categories of medical
professionals who are entitled to
medical benefits that is the doctors
nurses and those working with the
medical professionals such as for
example drivers of ambulances we have
adopted a number of measures which have
allowed us to basically supercharged the
whole system of medical aid ninety-five
thousand bats would be opened by the end
of April right 28th of April but today
we have reoriented a number of hospitals
and open up even more beds than that
because some of the regions are
suffering more than others now we have
one hundred and forty six thousand beds
across Russia ready to welcome mid
nineteen patients but also have ICU best
money to also have the special
information system to keep our hand on
the pulse on how many beds are available
and where all the patients are we have
now 36 percent of ICU bats out of all
the number of paths and they are ready
they are open they're free so we don't
think that there is any kind of deficits
right now there is no problem with
hospital admissions in the regions of
Russia we have allowed direct access to
this system so that every region could
see what is happening across all
hospital institutions all healthcare
clinics we are we are analyzing the
incoming information in experience well
we have a special analytics team to do
that today the number of hospitalized
patients is hitting those who have been
in recovering that is why we are
continuing to experience certain
on the bads capacity we are working with
the regions to tell them that they can
add more bats not ICU beds hospital
situated in the cities with the
population of 1 million that is 2 to 3
bears per 1000 people an average these
bats will be deployed if necessary first
foremost we are following closely the
situations with the patient's who need
immediate help because they have cancer
and other conditions these are very
serious issues and these people should
not be denied help monitoring situation
with the availability of PPE and that
has showing that today we have good
stable conditions we've been producing
multi years BP here in Russia putting
gowns for healthcare professionals we
are working on how the immunity is
created we are working with medical
professionals to get to know better
we've been testing new systems to
confirm new cases we are searching for
new drugs might be potentially used to
treat Kabat 19 some of them have already
proved to be quite effective and which
is good is that these drugs are produced
in full could be too early to say that
they are silver bullet but still there
are companies today which want to
exchange data exchange research
information and they want to chip in and
help us at the pre clinical trial stage
in conclusion I would like to say that
we continue our work on vaccines the
burial
that we are auditing the production
facilities that we have in order to
understand whether we can supercharge
the production when we have the vaccine
thank you I have listened to your report
I've read the report on the context if
you have with your foreign colleagues I
hope that this will be a good addition
to your work because we need to exchange
information in the situation like that
when all the world is sailing in these
nice trades our colleagues they
certainly determined to have positive
dialogue and cooperation yes thank you
we've been working with the ministers of
health care with those who have the
necessary experience and thank you very
much for organizing these connections
yes thank you nurse you said nick of
mysteries i think of colleagues the
government is implementing a package of
measures to support the economy of these
measures aimed at companies that work in
the industries that have suffered most
from the epidemic especially small and
medium businesses we have 11 sectors
currently over 6 billion people are
employed in this industries over 3.2
million employed in small and medium
businesses first we would like to extend
the time for them for the payment of the
salaries the payments of taxes and
payments have been deferred the total
amount of taxes deferred is over two
hundred seventeen billion people in the
future as you said the people will be
able to defer this payments to up to one
year people will not automatically get
the deferral we'll be able to get its
buy through applications
the only condition is to is that their
income is reduced by 10% we believe that
over 50,000 more enterprises will be
able to make use of these benefits from
May to June at the moment we can see
that those who have already completed
this application I have already been
given the deferrals now tax holidays
will be provided to citizens and
companies who had their incomes reduced
by over 30 percent currently the number
of people going to the banks asking for
restructure ization is over 35,000
applications out of which over 60% have
already been approved number of de-facto
restructure ization that have been
gathered for our 14,000 persons there
have been 44 thousand applications
16,000 of them have been approved tax
holidays will be provided for the amount
of 68 billion rubles I'm going to say
that this federal law also gave the
bank's an incentive to start with dr.
ization regulating the restrictor
ization purchases for themselves which
makes the process the whole process much
easier and streamlines that we are also
supporting Russian banks through the
program that allows entrepreneurs to
write of 2/3 of the sum of money intense
they need to pay current Li we have 1.2
billion worth of tax deferrals the
potential of this program is 300 billion
rubles as planned so we have
of work to do so the pearls in other
areas with respects to property have
been over 650 applications to prolong to
extend the payments with respect to fees
with respect to property
28500 enterprises have used this also
gave the right to private owners to
extend and defer payments until the
lockdown is over
[Music]
currently we provide we have set the
date for October 1st we introduce other
measures we have a program for
subsidized loans 6% for small and medium
sized enterprises who suffered from the
epidemic currently the program has been
extended to all companies respective of
their size and for micro enterprises and
smaller enterprises we have essential
enterprises is not a social enterprises
if at least one of the activities of the
official activities of this micro or
small enterprises is essential than this
enterprise can make use of the program
were introduced we have over thirty one
point five thousand applications by now
so currently the program is in full
force
well thousand applications
I've been approved by the banks and
eight thousand two loan agreements
25:21 billion rubles have been issued
this will help to approximately 280,000
people so the program was very effective
also we've extended the program of subs
program of subsidies back to loans which
has existed before the crisis but we
adapted it to the current environment we
have removed two limitations with
respect to the maximum size of the
refinancing of the loan is these money
this money is usually sent to finance
this the wages of the employees now
finally direct to help direct support of
the businesses we have been providing
all businesses with minimum wages for
their employees under the condition that
they maintain 80% 90% of their pre
co-leads
employment administrative costs are
being reduced our goals is to reduce the
non production costs of all businesses
and reduce the contacts between workers
and stuff in the administration in March
50,000 inspections have been halted by
the end of the year there will be almost
half a million less inspections also we
have automatically extended licenses
that were expiring this year about 66
hundred thousand different licenses and
other documents have been extended
we have also number of other laws
introduced help the businesses prominent
of them is to have the car industry and
with respect to equipping
cars and vehicles with a GLONASS system
we have a draft law to extend the
licenses we and we have a number of
other areas when we are helping the
businesses tomorrow this will be
discussed at a session of the government
another important area of our work is
that we are helping the critical
industries mr. bellos of has outlined
the key parameters the few criteria
currently the ministries have formed in
this released 472 areas over 100
enterprises 45% of them are industrial
center transportation etc measures to
support these enterprises include
subsidies from the federal budget these
enterprises will be no more than four
point five two five percent importance
to to get this information down to the
banks to for them to give loans to
transportation companies to housing etc
so the critical industries and critical
sectors these are the sectors that
require our immediate support though
there will be a total of four hundred
thirty six thousand billion rubles
provided to these sectors
on the 30th of April the first all loans
worth 12 billion rubles have been
approved so 15 days have passed since
then I believe that we have been able to
do this very quickly and expediently we
come up with a number of indicators
every day we calculate the indicator of
economic activity based on seven factors
use of electricity transportation of
cargo cars experts as of April 29th
economic activity has reduced by 33
percent compared to the time before the
lockdown measures as of today the
activity of companies and enterprises
and in the region in the regions has
been reduced so the general level of the
reduction of economic activity in the
country so different government
divisions regions are coming up with the
different plans to combat this situation
all these aspects will be discussed
later today thank you well much of what
I've heard has to do with the solutions
which we have already implemented you
reporters on the outcomes but there is
some other things which still needs to
be assessed so please you should dig
deeper to see how much money has been
allocated and
who should structure restructure their
operation because you should be working
on it supervising the whole effort now
mr. yogorov the federal taxation service
please good afternoon mr. Putin good
afternoon colleagues mr. former is like
to present the number of analytical
outcomes that we have talking about the
month of April excitin went down by 30
percent mostly because of the nitro
resources production cuts and of course
income taxes it went down by 14 percent
and it should be taking it account that
is being made at the same time when
salaries are issued so the industry
which was Dell the first immediate blow
we see that today we have 30 30 percent
of companies in the retail market
non-working and their revenues went down
by 25 facade we break it down into the
weeks of the restriction measures like
the first week and the last week that we
have now we can see that the number of
companies not working in the retail
business going up by again 25 percent
and 32 percent is the revenues which we
generate today also the consumption of
fuel went down in the first weeks but
today at the last week we have a huge
decrease accumulating this is 80% and so
the measures we adopt in order to
maintain the situation the desirable
level we have 7 million companies in
Russia and they've been given waivers
for their taxation documents they don't
need to file they documents for a while
they will not be d for some time all
these
actions have been stopped including for
those companies who work with foreign
currencies talking about the industries
which have been hit the hardest well
should break it down into two groups
these are the companies which are not
subjective paying excite-ation payments
and they can be entitled to extensions
there is a monetary Aman bankruptcy as
for small medium sized companies working
in the regions of Russia I can tell you
that in this area we have giving this
companies opportunity to automatically
respond their payments we've been giving
them subsidies to maintain jobs they'll
report on that later that's how the
industry is rich in suffering the most I
can save that one fourth of all
companies and entrepreneurs in Russia
are those who have been hit and
therefore they are allowed to receive
the help which we've been discussing
such as automaticall waivers companies
they don't need to pay their taxes today
it's been deferred to a later date
automatically we have a number of groups
of companies like that those who
received in March they will be paying
after six months those at the end of
March they'll be paying after four
months also we have 2017 billed rubles
giving the companies as financial help
we have 1.5 billion companies which are
to receive that help as of today I can
tell you that we so far have given 1.4
billion roubles that's because today we
have holidays and we are not receiving
any
applications for this help because of
that statistics shows that we will see
over 50,000 applications coming from
companies or across Russia and finally
the instructions which we were given to
subsidize companies who want to maintain
current job levels that decree was
issued on the 24th of April and we have
deployed every mechanism that we have in
order to issue those subsidies and that
was done starting from May the 1st at
midnight and let me again tell you which
companies are entitled to that help so
first these are the companies which are
small and medium sized those who operate
in the designated industry areas those
who have no major that's we know that
over 1.2 million companies are within
that group employing over 4 million
people and there is a reservation to
make that these are also entrepreneur so
not only companies but interpreters are
entitled to this financial help on the
measures that we have already adopted we
have issued recommendations to companies
who are entitled to such subsidies we
informed them through letters sonic
messages on how to apply for this help
also we have put all the information our
website and now people can put down
their first no insurance registrations
and this way they will get to know
whether they are entitled or not you can
file easily their applications through
the website they just need to choose
their current account number and put all
the nation into the designated boxes on
the page so that can be done for movie
personal accounts or through the
information systems usually used for
that purpose
and of course they can file written part
copies of their applications we are
processing all of that the timely manner
and as of today I can say that we have
seen 64,000 companies already filed
their applications you probably remember
we were told to start paying the money
from 18 sort of May and we'll do our
best you comply with that these
companies who have already filed the
mutation before will take a look at
whether they have the 10% and if they
did we will start issuing money
immediately of course we need to put up
a special service to show companies
entrepreneur's that the applications
have been received processed and
approved this way we will be monitoring
the whole process it will be a one-stop
shop you understand which stage we are
individual applications we also set up
an analytical mechanism to assess all
the existing types of taxpayers and that
system can help other ministries were or
receive the program of money allocations
that said all right thank you to the
acting Minister for construction and
utilities following the results of the
meeting we've had the number of measures
taken to support the construction
industry first of which is the mortgage
program
which means that we can take mortgage at
the rate of 6.5% over 20,000
applications have been submitted with
14,000 of them have been already
processed eleven thousand have been
accepted and over two thousand loans
worth six billion rubles have been
issued the dom RF foundation has been
operating the process would believe that
over 230,000 loans or will be issued
mortgages will be issued over the span
of this program now the measure we've
agreed upon is a program to subsidize
rates for construction companies will be
receive loans at the rate of 5.5% the
program will be operated by the same
foundation the third measure is the is
the help to the investors into housing
projects that were frauds defrauded we
have been working with the region's
currently about twenty four thousand
twenty four regions received our support
114 construction projects another
measure that is currently in progress
and will soon be approved is the state
guarantee guarantees with 50 billion
rubles to support the construction
industry also construction companies
receive this benefits receive these
rates will have
to maintain the number of employees they
have and also complete their housing
projects as scheduled for 2020 2021
Thank You colleagues does anyone else
want to add anything today's part of our
conversation or comment on anything okay
let's let me say this to conclude this
session this part of our session first
of all all of us companies citizens has
of companies shareholders must know must
realize and must have full information
of the types of support that the
government provides them with they need
to be informed this information needs to
be complete secondly everyone must know
how specifically they can use these
benefits this subsidies also the
procedures should be available to people
and finally everyone must be sure of the
positive that he or she will receive
these benefits because some of these
payments for example are slated for
later this month everyone must
understand what exactly is going to
happen in the upcoming days because the
main decisions by main hands of
companies most heads of companies will
be made after May 12
so please note that now let's move to
the second part of our discussion mister
Bava
had oversight in consumer protection and
human well-being this is the main
federal agency and the main a federal
medical professional in the company what
can you say about the gradual lifting of
lockdown measures please you have the
floor colleagues members of the
conference following your instruction we
have come up with a number of guidelines
to outline the indications which would
help to understand when and how we can
lift some of the restrictions measures
such we applied have curbing the outside
of the disease and for two months
my team is analyzing situation 24/7 and
here in Russia and also taking a look at
others experience we are a unique
country in a number of regions today we
have great of covered 19 confirmations
as three percent or less we have been
given additional powers to help us I'll
break and how to better understand how
to organize the lifting and special
measures we think that it will be better
to but it's all into three phases every
region can come up with its own region
specific measures the following criteria
should be taken into account first the
rate of new cases the availability of
beds for patients to be hospitalized and
also the testing capabilities in order
to understand how many people have
already been tested all these criteria
being assessed in retrospective one or
two weeks prior because this housing
incubation periods work we have
formulated the recommendations with one
goal in mind to
preserve the lives of our people we have
succeeded in platting of the curve there
hasn't been any major outbreak across
Russia and today following the state
home order people can communicate only
in between the family members or work
colleagues if that person goes to work
we believe that we can expand the number
of areas where people will be able to
have any context person for most people
will be entitled to do your physical
exercises or jogging outside or some
restricted areas nonetheless people are
to follow all the social distancing
rules also believe that small stores and
shops can be open larger stores will be
open only if they will be limiting the
number of her customers at the third
stage we believe it will be possible to
allow open up of course social
distancing
should be observed under less and the
stores will be able to stop limiting the
number of consumers be let in at the
same time also cafeterias and
restaurants will be able to open too
according to the new recommendations
decision on whether to lift the
restrictions or not will be made by the
head of region take into account the
situation of course if the situation
deteriorates these measures can be
brought back we have come up with a
number of detailed recommendations to
any kind of company any kind of industry
and how to follow the guidelines ensure
safety and protection experience shows
once all the guidelines are followed the
risk of contracting this virus is
minimal we have a number of agricultural
companies construction sites all
companies working in close complies with
the mid-nineteen guidelines which has
allowed us to prevent any outbreaks from
happening we're focusing our attention
on people which belonged to the
high-risk groups we
are the elders and particular ill
patient these people should be adopted
extra measures when they leave their
houses some of these companies and some
of the institutions together with
regional authorities have already
installed mask regimes as they are
called and that also helps us to curb
the outbreaks restrictions day is
something that we do in order to save
the population and it's up to the people
to decide how to follow them in the best
way possible we already seen some good
improvements in some of the regions
which shows that our work is not in vain
thank you and I would like to give the
floor to delegate Somalian mayor of
Moscow and ahead on the working group
working under the auspices of the State
Council thank you very much we were poor
and now let's proceed to this next
report Thank You mr. Putin yesterday at
your people discussed the measures
flying today related to lifting lock
down their measures I have to say that
the measures transitioning to other
stages the stage-by-stage easing out the
country of the lockdown
need to be divided into two stages the
first stage is the most severe stage it
has to do with the services sector so
basically has to do with people
interacting physically interacting as
services are provided to them like hair
salons trades
Brown's huge supermarkets etc so the
start of operation in these enterprises
can actually throw us back so we have
come up with a set of rigid criteria we
have agreed that we need to take into
account the specifics of each region so
that the system is less rigid and so
they stage by stage lifting of the
measures of the restrictions in other
enterprises such as construction
agriculture others need to be regulated
by the regions of Russia themselves
however they need to take into account
the conditions that have been set for
them by the doctors by the relevant
federal authorities and local
authorities as well so the there will be
two documents or two sectors first the
services sector that will be regulated
by doctors and as for industry and other
sectors this is the responsibility of
the hands of the regions as for Moscow
specifically we analyzed the situation
in detail with respect to what's
happening in the city recent day we have
increased by many fold the number of
tests and the trends that we see does
not clearly indicate that the rate of
infection is growing besides that
Moscow has a strong system of city scans
so we are testing people for pneumonia
and other coded related conditions which
allows us to see to to to find more
people with coded patients with kovat
which allows us to treat them at an
earlier stage I'd like to say that we
have been working with the Ministry of
Health that have been working with us we
have a network of centers to treat coded
[Music]
different regions and the main criteria
or further decisions to be made is that
in the upcoming two weeks these are the
two weeks then that will allow us to
actually make some conclusions over the
these two weeks we haven't seen a rise
in hospitalized patients so the number
of ICU patients is generally on the same
level so the situation is stabilizing
some respect
as for what decisions could be made in
this situation we believe that it is too
early for the service sector to remove
the lockdown measures unfortunately it
is the situation is not right yet
however this gives us an opportunity
to allow starting on May 12th to start
to let all construction companies and
all other industrial companies to start
operation which will allow over several
million Muscovites to return to work
this is very important for the country's
economy from Moscow's economy because
Moscow's enterprises create over 3.5
million jobs in the country especially
the construction industry and other
industry the energy industry we've
talked about that yesterday and you've
agreed with me that this decision is
possible however the lock down
restrictions will not be lifted yet the
general restrictions we will just be
allowing these enterprises these
industries to return to work and the
work of this enterprises needs to be
regulated according to the norms and
regulations set by our medical
professionals I believe that this is the
decision that is possible in Moscow
today thank you so much as to yesterday
we'll discuss this and I fully support
what you've said I believe that our
plans for opening after the majority of
companies for most manufacturing
industries and construction sites are
well rounded we need to do that in
ordination where the healthcare
professionals I'd like to remind you
that special attention should be paid
the companies need to be working
effectively and to make that happen the
whole chain of supply should be working
as clockwork
that's for you to do I don't think it
will be hard for you if you just need
you sit down with the heads of Russia's
region and to establish how the chain
supply chains are distributed across
Russia we need to lay down the
groundwork for future success now I
would like to go back to the first point
of the agenda I've heard nothing which
has to do with supporting the people who
work at the Social Welfare institutions
of course these is something for the
regional authorities to take care of so
again I would just like to hear more
about that from the Minister of Labour
and Social Welfare it's up to him to get
down and assessment and calculations as
well as I asking the heads of Russia's
region to be very careful with this very
problem and monitor this situation and
in conclusion who we and this advice
conference I would like to listen to the
report mr. Parker whether you have
anything to add Booton colleagues right
now we are entering a more difficult
period in terms of our economic
situation right now
most of the companies in Russia I've
been given help to make it through the
storms they've been entitled to a number
of benefits and bonuses and we see the
companies are actively applying for this
help companies are applying for loans to
pay salaries and we see that there is
already 2,000 applications more per day
and we believe that will be allocating
around 80 billion rubles to pay that
money you companies we have set certain
limits for such payments and I think
that we will use all the money that we
have prepared by the end of March by the
24 months to be precise banks are
working all the applications coming in
and we see that there is one problem now
the number of approved applications is
way lower than that of the applications
received but I know that sperm bank and
BTB and other banks have very rigid and
very big procedures in place you approve
such applications probably we need to
accelerate this process
you're right saying that right now we
should be preparing to launch a number
of companies interaction and we need to
prevent any supply chains from hanging
loose we'll add additional value to our
economy I believe that there are two
opportunities we can snatch most of the
supplies are changing on Niger and
medium sized companies which are part of
the essential industries and I'd like to
reach out to the pads of Russia's region
using this opportunity to remind you of
the lists of companies which are
designated as the essential union
companies we have outlined
cuteness supporting reporting which is
to be done on a two-week basis thirty to
sixty percent of the companies now are
operational and what is important right
now is that this information should be
coming through an expedient way it
should be added to the information
centers which would later on distributed
so if we receive more information we'll
be able to understand better how the
supplying chains are working and where
we need to help companies out with the
bottlenecks that they experience for
example we believe that many companies
today work in the atmosphere of
unpredictability and they may be better
off saving money up not paying salaries
that is exactly why we now have this
program to subsidize salary payments as
soon as we started this program the
banks have been overflowing these
applications whole limit for the money
to be allocated and has already been
used up I had to micromanage the process
to prevent any problems from arising to
help thanks with coping with this influx
of applications we need to care for the
interest of banks for the interest of
companies this well if the company is
affected you need to receive help and
now again I'd like to say that it is for
the governance of Russian precision
charities to monitor this process
because if we break this supply chains
then we'll have a lot of problems on our
hands and if we succeed in giving the
money timely and in the food then
companies will be able to operate
normally thank you now colleagues
as you know we have introduced a number
of restrictions in order to curb the
outbreak of combat 19 an additional
powers have been given to governance of
the Russia's regions and you understand
the reason why situation is as follows
the country is huge and everywhere
situation is different practice shows
experience shows that we've been right
other countries by the way followed in
our footsteps well it would be only good
if they succeed this way and I would
like to reach out to mr. Bello acting
head of Russia's government and every
colleague of mine working at the
government and working in the regions of
Russia as well as the working group
headed by mayor of Moscow Banyon we need
to coordinate our efforts we need to
continue working on the Orang time
measures and on the ways to lift these
restrictions and it's up to the
government to oversee the whole process
I hope that the regions will listen to
that and the government will also
supercharge its work directly
intervening where necessary because
right now we are approaching a very
important stage of our work as I said in
my introduction remarks we should not be
getting ahead of ourselves because we
can experience a throwback but we should
be stalling as well we need to work
consistently make him gradual progress
and it is key that the government
oversees all the efforts across Russia
and I hope our work will be just as
effective and efficient as it used to be
[Laughter]